[Musique]
nous sommes le mardi 13 décembre
bienvenue pour cette édition du 7 8 elle
les inviter celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité et aujourd'hui othman nas ou
le vice-président les républicains de la
région ile de france chargée des
affaires internationales du tourisme il
revient sur ses missions aux côtés de
valérie pécresse dans un contexte
difficile l'attractivité est en net
recul depuis la promulgation de l'état
d'urgence un peu activités de ce
territoire et nous parlerons aussi de
l'actualité locale othman nation est
aussi un élu local attrapé à saint
quentin en yvelines et puis là peter
dîner comédien metteur en scène magicien
une passion qui l'a découvert à sept ans
et qu'il transmet aujourd'hui aux plus
petits installés à plaisir il leur est
sur scène actuellement à paris et son
ouvrage l'atelier de magie sans larmes
vient d'être réédité bonsoir à tous les
deux et merci d'être venus pour cette
édition othman nasri donc en charge
notamment des questions de tourisme pour
la région de l'île de france
on va débuter avec cette proposition ce
choix de valérie pécresse de mettre en
place des volontaires du tourisme 200
étudiants pour les fêtes de fin d'année
ils sont payés autour de 250 euros pour
deux semaines d'accueil et de conseil
aux touristes dans la capitale
ça va servir à quoi concrètement quelles
seront leurs missions vous l'avez dit on
un contexte touristique très difficile
on perd plus d'un million de touristes
étrangers cette année il ya l'effet des
attentats il ya plus globalement un
certain nombre de difficultés de la
destination
donc c'est aussi l'occasion pour les
membres les temps sont difficiles de
tout remettre à plat de voir ce qui
fonctionne et ce qui fonctionnait pas et
en l'occurrence hurle à une faiblesse
sur laquelle l'objectif des volontaires
du tourisme c'est ce dispositif qui a
été lancée aujourd'hui parmi d'autres
mesures la présidente valérie pécresse
avait annoncé et il ya maintenant
quelques semaines c'est de renforcer
l'accueil
un accueil qui soit en langue étrangère
sur les sites touristiques sur les
espaces publics pour accueillir orienter
et guider les tous les touristes
tout simplement pour l'heure que ses
jours soient le plus simple possible et
donc effectivement c'est un dispositif
qui est ouvert aux étudiants dans les
métiers du tourisme qui sont formés
encadré et rémunérés pour avoir aussi
une expérience professionnelle vous
savez qu'on a cette difficulté dans la
région des stages et c'est un sujet qui
nous tient à coeur on a aussi lancé une
initiative sur les cent mille stage pour
permettre à des jeunes d'avoir des
expériences professionnalisant qui sont
ici rémunérés en plus au-delà de ce que
la loi
prévoir mais l'objectif essentiel c'est
de donner le meilleur accueil possible
aux touristes français et surtout
étrangers qui viennent nous rendre
visite pour redonner de l'attractivité à
la destination les stages sont un outil
pédagogique et non un moyen d'avoir de
la main d'oeuvre exploitables c'est ce
que dit l'unef
à propos de ces sept ce dispositif
volontaire de tourisme c'est l'objectif
d'avoir aussi une main d'oeuvre à pas
cher c'est absurde parce que l'unef est
un peu contradictoire l'unef vous
d'autres d'ailleurs je crois que comme
je le disais on a besoin de stars et
vous cesser d'opposer tout le temps les
stages et les s'est dit on a besoin des
deux et il ya des jeunes aujourd'hui qui
n'arrive pas à avoir un stage et on le
sait c'est le premier pied à l'étrier
avant d'avoir aussi ensuite un parcours
professionnel je le disais ça s'inscrit
dans le cursus des jeunes s'agit de
jeunes qui sont les métiers du tourisme
des métiers d'accueil qui sont
volontaires demandeurs pour le faire
former encadrer rémunérés dans le cadre
de leur cursus
donc il n'y a pas de sujet se fait à
dire que c'est pas tout stage ou 0 stage
l'arrêter c'est d'ailleurs que la région
a aussi un dispositif d'accueil qui est
permanent mais il ya aussi de la place
pour un certain nombre de stages et moi
je suis fier de permettre à des jeunes
de poursuivre leur cursus sont à ce
sujet là y compris sur l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines de l'accès
aux stages voilà donc il faut arrêter
les polémiques politiciennes et les
postures on a aussi besoin ce rapport de
stage et les séries en jouant très clair
bien sûr que l'on vient de faire c'est
volontaire du tourisme c'est le
l'appellation officielle alors vous
l'avez dit attentats intempéries et
grève entre janvier et août la région
ile de france a perdu au moins 7 149
millions d'euros c'est énorme y aura 23
millions d'euros qui seront consacrés
par la région dans le cadre du
dispositif du budget 2010 est où on a
parlé de ce dispositif des volontaires
du tourisme il y en a d'autres il ya on
peut citer aussi le city pass par
exemple ça fait partie des différentes
choses citi passe ce sera un ticket
d'accès unique aux transports oui ce qui
existe dans beaucoup de capitales ça
paraît évident qu'il faut qu'on est ici
un accès au transport adapté aux
touristes avec une carte unique sur
laquelle on peut aussi avoir une offre
culturelle une offre touristique avec
l'accès à des musées etc etc
c est une évidence ça existe dans
beaucoup de capital touristique et puis
effectivement nous c'est un vieux
serpent de mer ça fait dix ans que
malheureusement ça ma part puisse se
faire et donc aujourd'hui il ya une
volonté pour qu'on puisse le faire dans
les plus brefs délais avant la ryder cup
puisque c'est un événement touristique
majeure qui va servir
aussi de jalons mais il ya d'autres
mesures on peut parler de sécurité
touristique aussi puisque au delà des
attentes à on a un problème de sécurité
au quotidien et donc cette région la
région ile de france va consacrer l'an
prochain des moyens pour qu'il y ait des
commissariats maudite positionner sur
les sites touristiques à une convention
avec le ministère de l'intérieur pour ci
sera signé jeudi et qui prévoit donc
effectivement à la fois un volet
sécurité sur les commissariats j'ai
envie de dire de la vie courante et mais
aussi les commissariats mobile
positionné sur les sites touristiques ce
qui est aussi une demande des
professionnels du tourisme se sont eux
qui nous ont sollicités sur ces
questions on est sur une question de
lexique aussi mais état d'urgence ça ne
fait pas forcément vendre aussi par
rapport à la région valérie pécresse l'a
dit y'a pas longtemps elle souhaitait
qu'on parle plutôt d'état de haute
sécurité
c'est une vraie difficulté sur les mots
ou ça change devrait véritablement
quelque chose
bah ça change quelque chose puisque pour
un touriste étranger qui voit état
d'urgence c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement angoissant et on a
l'impression que c'est un état de guerre
civile et on sait qu'il ya une
désaffection d'un certain nombre de
touristes notamment les plus éloignés à
cause de ce terme pour ce que demande la
présidente valérie pécresse est assez
simple finalement c'est qu'on garde les
mesures mais simplement qu'on installe
ses dé talla qui visiblement parti pour
rester dans la durée avec une
appellation d'état de haute sécurité par
exemple
ça paraît de bon sens mais ça fait quand
même un petit moment qu'on le conte le
demander aujourd'hui malheureusement on
n'a pas pu le gouvernement en tout cas
n'a pas retenu cette proposition là qui
aurait permis aussi de faire revenir les
touristes plus facilement parce que ce
problème de tourisme se posant bien
évidemment sur la capitale n'est pas
uniquement dans les différents
départements les yvelines sont
principalement concernées il ya nombreux
sites touristiques entre les parc de
thoiry
le centre france miniature aussi sur la
ville d'elancourt non loin d'ici on
pourrait aussi citer bien évidemment le
château de versailles qui a vu sa
fréquentation baisser aussi durant la
période estivale alors votre mission
c'est aussi de faire rayonner cette île
de france à l'étranger
pas uniquement manière de matière de
tourisme d'ailleurs vous étiez aux états
unis à quelques mois au maroc plus
récemment l'objectif de ce dernier
voyage c'est de développer aussi les
relations économiques
ça a débouché sur quoi concrètement quel
bilan vous en fait c'était au début du
mois de décembre pour le déplacement
marque
on est en train de repenser la stratégie
internationale de la région parce que ce
qu'il faut faire maintenant à
l'international c'est du vrai
développement économique et c'est du
vrai que développement et c'est pas
simplement de l'affichage leur
effectivement on a des amendes parce
qu'on a des pays qui nous sont proches
géographiquement humainement
culturellement et sur lesquels
aujourd'hui on n'arrivait pas à avoir
une relation
je qualifierais de gagnant gagnant et on
a encore une fois dans ces pays-là des
homologues qui veulent être traités
comme des partenaires
donc avec la rue au maroc c'est la
région de casablanca qui grosses régions
économiques a été retenue nous avons
également signé un accord avec la région
du grand alger il en sera de même en
tunisie en plus de ce que nous faisons
dans d'autres pays vous l'avez rappelé
nous étions aux états unis avec à chaque
fois la même logique c'est que il ya les
acteurs franciliens ici publics et
privés qui peuvent être mis en relation
avec des acteurs là bas pour faire du
vrai développement économique et donc à
chaque fois nous partons qu'une
délégation d'entreprises
ça donne aussi une entreprise
francilienne accès à un certain nombre
de marchés
ça ne débouche sur des contrats
concrètement il ya des contrats qui sont
signés à l'issue de ses déplacements
oui alors je veux prendre un exemple
puisque c'était il ya quelques jours
il est par exemple le pôle de
compétitivité cap digital qui est un des
meilleurs pôles de compétitivité ici en
ile-de-france sur le numérique qui qui
vient de signer dans le cadre de cet
accord là avec son homologue au maroc je
peux parler de ce que d'une question du
traitement des déchets et sur lesquels
on est très implantée sur lesquels on
peut faire gagner un certain nombre de
marchés à nos entreprises etc
et c'est donc à la fois c'est du gagnant
pour nos entreprises ici en
ile-de-france puis c'est vrai pour le
tourisme mais c'est vrai au delà
j'aurais pu le dire c'est plus de cinq
cent mille emplois ici un an qu'il faut
qu'on aille vendre la destination depuis
plus globalement ça permet aussi de
faire du vrai qu'au développement
puisque disons le clairement l'objectif
c'est aussi de développer l'emploi sur
les pays dans les pays d'origine sur ces
territoires qui sont des territoires
partenaires et là dessus nous sommes
parfaitement à l'aise à réinventer si
vous voulez une politique internationale
qui soit digne d'une grande région comme
l'île de france
on va pas faire un bilan complet de
l'action valérie pécresse depuis un an
mais ça fait effectivement tout juste un
an qu'elle a pris la tête de la région
votre poste de vice-président vous
l'avez depuis le mois de juillet à peu
près c'était au moment de l'été cette
vice-présidence en charge du tourisme
notamment
quel bilan vous vous en faites vous êtes
satisfait des mesures qui ont été prises
j'imaginais ce que vous avez le
sentiment que les choses sont allées
aussi vite que vous le souhaitiez ce qui
est agréable pour un jeune élu comme moi
c'est de constater qu'effectivement ce
qui avait été dit avant la campagne y
fit ensuite ça je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui voit là c'est qu'on
vous remet dans une période de défiance
du politique et valérie pécresse pour le
coup tout le monde ça douala dire que ce
qui était les engagements qui ont été
pris avant la campagne les deux tirs ont
déjà été pris on va tous se produire
leur effet maintenant je pense aux
transports qui est un bon sujet mais la
rénovation qu'elle avait engagée elle a
été votée et financer donc on est là
dessus vraiment ça c'est une grande
fierté on peut prendre les mesures est
paru le déménagement du siège de la
région qui
aujourd'hui les beaux quartiers de paris
et qui déménage à saint-ouen souci
d'économie d'optimisation à partir de
2018 c'est dans moins d'un an c'est dans
un an maintenant
donc moi je suis extrêmement fier de
pouvoir dire que le mandat que nous ont
donné les français bien sûr tout sur
l'ensemble des huit départements de la
région
et bien ce mandat-là idée il est tenu il
est tenu avec des difficultés avec un
contexte qui n'est pas facile mais les
engagements pris sont tenus et je crois
que c'est vraiment le plus important et
c'est en tout cas pour moi une grande
fierté
il ya plein d'autres sujets dont on
aurait pu parler avec vous mais je vous
inviterai à venir sur le plateau les
actualités locales parce que la trappe
aussi une vraie actualité locale on en
parlera je vous renvoie à nos prochaines
éditions du journal il ya sept national
10 notamment le dossier d'enfouissement
de la nationaliste qui va avancer de
demain il y aura une signature notamment
présence de valérie pécresse
concernant l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 et un budget de 95 millions
d'euros il y aura 27 millions d'euros
qui seront investis par la région sur ce
le sujet vous y serez présent d'ailleurs
lors de cette signature demain à trappes
est ce que vous êtes amateurs de magie
écoutez on politique non mais dans la
vie des jeunes coureurs du tour de magie
de passe passe en politique vous
présente plus tard dit bonsoir et
bienvenue donc sur ce plateau vous êtes
magiciens comédiens ventriloque aussi
vous allez nous présenter dans un
instant bobby vous êtes de plaisir votre
particularité vous vous adressez aux
plus jeunes aux tout petits la magie dès
le premier âge on va voir un petit
extrait d'un nouveau spectacle et puis
on parle de votre actualité juste après
ils ne font jamais nourri le mal ou bon
sens parce que si on le boudin ballon au
centre
forcément ça oblige avec les centres au
bout et si vous mettez le centre en
douceur les affaires en main au milieu
du goût du centre
résultats résultat vous aurez un bout
soit sur vous vous en les deux bouts et
en bout de bons centres peter dinet
d'autres invités ils parlent magie avec
othmana through un peu pendant ce
plateau mons en belgique
bonsoir bonsoir mobile vous accompagne
et vous tutoyez tu accompagnes peter
dean saunders et pourquoi peter dean à
choisir je peux être m'adresser
directement à celui qui seront
derrière toi pourquoi avoir avoir choisi
de vous adresser aux tout petits aux
plus jeunes alors c'est un c'est un
choix délibéré j'ai travaillé pendant
très longtemps pour les adultes
j'ai fait les treilles pendant 20 ans
sur des bateaux de croisière donc avec
une clientèle très seniors et lorsque
j'ai posé le sac à terre eh bien j'ai
découvert le spectacle pour enfants que
j'avais déjà abordé il ya quelques
années avant j'étais passionné par la
formation surtout par l'initiation à la
magie parce que contrairement à une
vieille légende urbaine
la magie n'est pas du tout fait pour les
enfants on entend souvent dire la magie
c'est pour les enfants alors que la
magie n'est pas du tout un concept
enfantin salles et des frais où ils font
pas la différence entre la réalité et et
la magie en fait c'est le pouvoir
l'imaginer ces retours un enfant tout
est magique et je peux y mettre arrivé
de faire dans un spectacle à l'époque
j'avais un numéro avec des oiseaux sa
part des colombiens joue un petit garçon
est venu me voir ni même c'est normal tu
es magicien ça n'avait pas du tout épaté
de voir apparaître des colombes
parce que ben j'étais magicien c'était
une chose acquise donc maintenant fais
moi autre chose qui m'étonne et c'est là
que j'ai découvert que les enfants
avaient une conception de la magie
complètement différente et qu'il fallait
aller vers les enfants rentrés dans leur
univers apprendre à les connaître
apprendre découvrir donc je sais passer
par la formation s'est passé par la
découverte beaucoup de rencontres avec
des spécialistes de la petite enfance
passe aussi par la fente rien gagné par
donc voilà bobby votre relais c'est mon
relais c'est en même temps
c'est en même temps la personne qui peut
se permettre de dire tout ce que je ne
peux pas dire mais toujours à toute
façon toujours très corps avec un bobby
sens sinon si fort il coule ou pour les
plus petits ben oui ça commence
il faut faire très attention je
travaille à partir de 2 ans ou deux ans
mais ce matin par exemple attrape 3
votre commune j'ai travaillé dans une
crèche pour des tout-petits de cas à
partir de le plus jeune devais avoir 14
mois je crois et jusqu'à deux ans et on
a fait de la magie aussi alors c'est des
séquences très très courte c'est une
magie complètement adaptée alors à leur
perception mais c'est quelque chose de
magique et puis les petites étoiles
qu'on voit dans les yeux des enfants bas
sont les mêmes classes vous aimez c'est
l'interaction l'émotion particulièrement
totalement entre laisser l'émotion pour
vous et on a forcément avec les enfants
il ya des réactions spontanées
de toute façon je crois que la magie
n'existe que si elle est génératrice
d'émotions
un magicien qui fait des tours pour moi
n'est pas un magicien
d'ailleurs le nom si la chose qui me met
en colère chaque fois qu'on me voit
exige aussi magicien parfaitement un
tour je déteste faire des tours parce
qu'un tour pour moi c'est une
démonstration d'aspirateur bon je fais
voir quelque chose oui ça apples et bien
entendu la personne qui est en face de
moi va vouloir chercher comment ça
marche comment j'ai fait mais pendant
qu'elle cherche comment j'ai fait elle
n'est plus dans l'émotion donc je vais
rater mon propos donc alors que si on
arrive à emmener le spectateur à lui
faire lâcher prise
et bien ce moment là tout est possible
et on s'aperçoit que la magie beaucoup
plus plus large que le simple fait de
faire apparaître disparaître trop
regarder l'intérêt une évolution de la
magie des spectacles de magie ces
dernières années grâce à maman
aujourd'hui et j'admirais beaucoup d
artistes qui se produisent à destination
d'un public plus adulte en bien sûr mais
mais la magie a eu un renouveau une
évolution
alors il ya un renouveau qui est
équivalent à ce qui s'est passé que le
cirque à une époque on avait dans ce
qu'on appelait l'ancien si réussir
traditionnelle et puis l arrivée du
nouveau cirque elle reçoit la troupe de
bobby ils savent dans le micro aux
attentes au micro on faire vous voilà
nous a coupé ses au lycée aussi comme le
sim traditionnelle donc on lui reprocher
d'être un petit peu poussif d'être un
petit peu ringard ce qui était vraiment
pas très gentil mais est arrivé un
cirque beaucoup plus contemporain où on
allait très loin
je me souviens à dar k os par exemple
qui qui faisaient des numéros
d'acrobatie ou de jonglerie avec des
tronçonneuses des choses comme ça
c'était très très violent il fallait
passer par ct par cette étape il ya eu
le cirque du soleil qui est arrivé la
magie vit la même chose actuellement et
ce qu'on appelle le mouvement de la
magie moderne qui essaye de mettre non
plus justement l'acte magique en avant
mais l'émotion magique en avant et
l'artiste s'efface presque derrière la
magie qu'il produit ce qui rend les
choses beaucoup plus beaucoup plus forte
pour le spectateur puisque lâcher prise
devient possible et ça depuis quelques
années il ya de beaucoup de troupes qui
qui se dirige dans ce dans ce sens et
qui font évoluer grandir la magie je
crois qu'on n'a pas encore tout dit en
magie et vous en dit beaucoup parce que
vous êtes aussi auteur d'un ouvrage
alors je veux juste profiter des 30
dernières secondes qui va nous rester
parce que ça passe très vite pour en
parler je vais vous les emprunter mais
pour pour les montrer à l'antenne
notamment celui ci l'atelier de magie
sans larmes on en revient à un petit peu
ce qu'on disait au début c'est que pour
expliquer la magie aux enfants et il
faut pas casser leur rêve donc l'exemple
allemand parce que si on apprend la
mafia un enfant uniquement par le truc
l'enfant croyant à la magie va se dire
mais tout ce qu'on m'a raconté c'était
c'était des histoires la magie n'existe
pas et généralement la réaction d'un
enfant qui en fait dans un tour saint
aubin sénile ça marche comme ça c'est
nul
alors que si on ne fait rêver et bien
automatiquement il va prendre plaisir à
faire de la magie mais il faut y aller
par étapes
alors au début l'enfant et spectateurs
des tours qu'on va lui apprendre donc il
est son propre spectateurs ensuite il
devient spectateur acteur c'est qu'il
reste spectateur de ce qu'il fait mais
en même temps il sait qu il en train de
faire un acte magique et ensuite
lorsqu'il a suffisamment évolué dans son
développement
eh bien il va devenir acteur acteurs sûr
qu'il sait et il maîtrise tous qu'il va
présenter en magie et donc il peut
accepter beaucoup plus facilement le
fait que la magie
j'ai à dire je dis souvent on joue à
être des magiciens on fait comme si on
était des magiciens les vrais magiciens
font pas comme ça mais si on fait bien
personnes vers la différence il y a cet
ouvrage donc que vous pouvez
vous procurer pourquoi pas une idée
aussi pour les cadeaux du père noël cet
ouvrage que vous voyez là il ya aussi un
site internet pour connaître toutes les
dates de spectacles qui s'est affiché
une adresse mail tous les numéros de
téléphone se sont affichés pendant
l'entretien pour permettre de vous
contacter parce que vous vous produisez
sur scène du côté de paris vous
intervenez aussi vous faites des
spectacles vous l'avais dit dans
différentes écoles des établissements
chez les particuliers aussi quelquefois
ils peuvent contacter le par les flics
pour les spectacles pour les tout petits
dès 2 3 ans vous pouvez emmener vos
enfants découvrir la magie merci
beaucoup d'être venus et tangi merci et
merci bobines bardon bobines oublier
était bien seul sur le plateau et merci
aux menaces congo qu'une déesse venus
parler de politique en plateau c'est la
fin du set 8 les invités
[Musique]